los angeles the place i left it's going
great over there things are going just
fantastically well
if you've been wondering where your
missing package went from fedex or
amazon or ups the answer is it's
probably on the train tracks over in la
there's tape that has now emerged of
these train tracks in la the union
pacific rail yard over in la and it's
just boxes as far as the eye can see
just empty boxes piles on piles of empty
boxes just trash everywhere that is not
because people just like littering it's
because people are jumping aboard the
union pacific freight trains they are
opening
the
enormous
metal boxes and they are just taking
stuff out and stealing it
that's all that is happening you can see
in this video just the trash everywhere
here's an amazon package for example and
the reporter picks it up
checks the address unopened
it turns out
that many of these packages have just
been reported as not delivered
because of course they weren't
delivered
people stealing rapid tests
people stealing whatever they can
because why the hell not because law
order does not exist in the city of los
angeles anymore we even have
fishing lures
oh good well i'm glad that they got some
fishing lures that's that's really
important by the way we have all sorts
of this this this sort of footage this
this footage is uh is all over the place
there there's a
top-down shot of the entire rail yard
and it's just covered in boxes just
covered in boxes according to cnn photos
and videos showing piles of empty boxes
littered alongside rail tracks in l.a
county california have gone viral as
shipping companies say they've had a
dramatic spike in railroad theft some of
the boxes are packages from companies
like ups amazon and fedex union pacific
one of the country's largest railroad
companies say it may avoid operating in
la county at all following the spike in
thefts which it blames on lacks
prosecution of crimes the containers and
trains are locked but can be broken into
union pacific said last month in a
letter to the la district attorney that
saw a 160 percent year-over-year
increase in theft in l.a county
the company claims a december 2020
special directive issued by d.a george
gascon changed how low-level offenses
are prosecuted and that has contributed
to the uptick
union pacific said in its letter in the
last three months of the year made over
100 arrests of active criminals
vandalizing our trains in partnership
with lapd but union pacific which has
its own police department with
jurisdiction over the 32 000 miles of
tracks and owns said that even as it has
expanded security resources and
partnered more closely with local law
enforcement the problem isn't going away
after being arrested individuals are
released from custody within 24 hours
yes they arrest all these people
and then they put them in jail within 24
hours they are gone they're out back to
robbing trains
this is great
and uh this isn't like the jesse james
gang here these are not geniuses these
are people who are literally just
jumping on slow-moving trains and
popping open the lock with a with a bolt
cutter and then just stealing stuff
i love what cnn says this is pretty
great they tried to associate this not
with criminal policy both poverty crime
is associated with increases in poverty
which has increased during the pandemic
okay first of all what is the evidence
that poverty has increased during the
pandemic and general levels
actually the amount of money in people's
pockets is more than it was at the
beginning of the pandemic because of the
amount of government spending
the county's directive was intended to
combat social ills that come from
misdemeanor convictions such as
difficulties with employment housing
education government benefits and
immigration so
cnn's coverage is amazing that's in the
news coverage you want to just you know
print a press release from the lada's
office that made this happen
gascon said studies show that
prosecution of the offenses driving the
bulk of misdemeanor cases have minimal
or even negative long-term impacts on
public safety our office is committed to
working with law enforcement to ensure
collective safety across l.a county's
sprawling infrastructure whether it's at
our port or on our railroad tracks
sure
the association of american railroads
expressed concern about the crime
increase
they said in coordination with local law
and where necessary federal law
enforcement partners the industry is
committed to pursuing all avenues
necessary to address this criminal
behavior all right we'll get to more of
this in just one second first if you
were a train robber and you were seeking
to grab yourself a great mattress the
first thing you would look for is a
helix sleeve package because let's be
real about this helix sleep is fantastic
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody is unique felix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers helix
even has mattresses with specialized
cooling technology if you and your
family can never agree on the
temperature of the thermostat so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
and they've been recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as the go-to solution for
improving sleep got a 10-year warranty
you have to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix even has financing options
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away my wife
and i prize our sleep on our helix sleep
mattress you will do the same just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
and meanwhile
crime in la continues to get worse and
worse according to tmz laurie laughlin
and massimo
gianouli are now crime victims they've
learned that their house was hit by
burglars who walked away with a million
bucks in jewelry
apparently the robbery went down on
january 3rd they weren't at home the
break-in and theft were discovered by a
housekeeper law enforcement sources told
tmz the thieves smashed a bedroom window
at their la area home they were all
dressed in black they wore masks cop
novas from surveillance cams once inside
they stole lori's jewelry box which
contained super expensive bling
cops don't know if they were
specifically targeted or if this was
just a random burglary
cops believe a south american burglary
crew pulled off the heist apparently
they traveled to american hitler america
hit locations and then quickly leave the
country
so that's uh that's that's nice
everything going really well in la
things going great in new york as well
by the way
over the weekend an asian woman was
pushed to her death at a subway station
in times square
authorities have a suspect in custody
who turned himself in after allegedly
pushing the 40 year old new york woman
off the qr platform near 42nd street and
broadway and onto the tracks in front of
an oncoming train
and by the way that is a really really
crowded area 42nd street and broadway is
like right center of the city that's
smack dab center of the city 42nd and
broadway that's literally where times
square is
the victim whose identity has been
withheld while officials notify her
family died at the station
subway passengers alerted transit police
after the woman fell onto the tracks
around 9 39 a.m the suspect was not
apprehended at the station later turned
himself into transit police the incident
was unprovoked the victim has no
interaction with the subject prior
according to the police
apparently the suspect initially
targeted another woman on the platform
and then he became physically violent
with the 40 year old victim
assistant chief jason wilcox said he
approaches her he gets in her space she
gets very very alarmed she tries to move
away from him and he gets close to her
and she she feels he was about to
physically push her onto the train as
she's walking away she witnesses the
crime when he pushes our other victim in
front of the train
apparently this guy has now been charged
61 years old he's now been charged with
murder
his criminal history includes multiple
prior arrests and he has been on parole
no no you don't mean that a man who
pushes women under train tracks has been
in jail before and is on parole for no
reason he does have in the past three
emotionally disturbed encounters with us
that we have documented said the cops
investigators believe the man was
experiencing homelessness at the time of
the assault
so new york city's strategy to leave
mentally ill homeless people on the
streets is paying off dividends
in recent months there have been several
instances of people being stabbed
assaulted or shoved onto the tracks at
stations in the bronx brooklyn and at
times square
eric adams has been mayor for a couple
of weeks he noted that a perception of
danger could drive more people to eschew
the subway complicating the city's
economic recovery he said we want to
continue to highlight how imperative it
is that people receive the right mental
health services particularly on our
subway system to lose a new yorker in
this fashion will only continue to
elevate the fears of individuals not
using our subway system yeah you think
you think
okay the
by the way
was this an anti-asian hate crime
unclear
we we we don't know
we know there's been a lot of crime
against asian americans in new york city
that's for sure
it remains an incredible story that new
york la chicago these places continue to
think that a wonderful wonderful idea is
to let
people
off the uh off the hook for prior crimes
by the way the suspect in this case is
indeed black and the black suspect
pushed the asian victim onto the train
tracks but
if there's been a white person pushing
an asian person onto a train tracks you
get a hate crime investigation if it's a
black person pushing an asian woman onto
train tracks and murdering her uh then
no hate crime investigation at all
also homelessness is is really just a
question of human freedom
that's really what it's about it's about
human freedom
well seems democratic policy failing
wherever it is tried as always as always
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video